[Musique]
au début
jaloux de l'air cemaa couverture
politique
si vous découvrez ma couleur
effectivement c'est dégueulasse voilà
sans rigoler avec la teinture cammas
audi réagissent le prof de d'aquagym tu
fais à quoi sert à quoi j'ai
hashtag casquette parce que salle pokou
bien entendu merci conseil sur mes
coiffure alors en fait à la boule ou que
je fasse ça pour quoi j'ai fait des
cheveux parce que on sait bleus dans ma
vie ces bleus dans mon coeur mais ça
mais non dans la gueule de quelqu'un je
me suis fait une petite pause et c'est
une petite reine mais bon tu as un
magasin en dur bien voulu faire comme
moi pareil sodomie moi aussi j'aimerais
vous
[Rires]
on est autour s'est réduit et thierry a
sorti de très bonnes vannes thierry
moreau un instant il a dit vous avez vu
même ici bernard se fait virer ces
tribus à bernard montiel est parti il
avait un truc avec le gouvernement il
sait pas s'ils vont confiné voilà une
région dont qu'ils sont en train de
boire ça et qu'il a sa place bien sûr au
prix de macron dès qu'ils ont une
décision à prendre même capillaire il
appelle bernard montiel jamais sûr que
ce soit la bonne solution mais il
appelle quand même non
tout